Oh welcome to this where this happens
the last one the last round
[Laughter]
you never seen the Rocky porno rock hard
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Bob for another game
and Baba's never played goat simulator
so we're just gonna fire it up and let
it go and see what happens go Bob go yes
Ram that car yes exactly
I forget that you haven't played this at
all look that man it's ok it's ok calm
down ok things are fine oh sorry dude
just killed that man that's all how do i
how do I eat press e to lick things
that's generally gonna be the way he's
screwed
Jesus hey bro what are we doing right
here I'm pretty sure hundreds of
thousands of people saw that Bonnie
really likes propane tanks oh really
yeah she really likes propane guys what
fire nah she's fine her legs are just
bending backwards this natural she's uh
[Music]
zoom in on that toe Barry Barry [ __ ]
that guy as long as my tongue not it's
not like Spider Man slingshot you can't
just shoot although someone should make
a mod for that in the workshop the
spider-man spider goat
oh god I'm older face by there we go
Spyder go does whatever a spider goat
does Tani's wing problem is tongue oh
look out here comes it not sponsored by
the simpsons movie should be beats
though it's just like it's good there's
the bell ring
you can if you ragdoll in there go goat
in here I gotta make up for something oh
I thought his mouth that's gaping open
like that oh it is it is fans up there
on right there that can probably get you
all the way to the roof of there so why
does this exist the gainer is there some
sort of storage yes there actually is
the maker of this game made this um how
do you hit fans jump on them I told you
from the beginning you had to jump on
the fan you you're the one who hasn't
been jumping on the fan there you go and
you can jump on the other one to give
more points and go higher wait don't
jump on them repeatedly little higher
anyway so the maker this game oh oh made
this guy you're not gonna need to go
back on the back hit the trampoline
Supertramp so the maker of this game
worked on a team that was making my
story because you're all just in the
town okay I'll just walk around casually
okay cool Hey okay jetpack only if you
assume what a jetpack is okay so um to
activate the jetpack press the button
Jesus Christ our button everybody there
you go this is not handled it doesn't
handle it all actually you can't control
yeah like turn it on okay oh you ran
into the studio this is the studio I was
trying to talk about that actually made
the game alright coffee stain hey cause
it's going to say hi to them I think
they must appreciate your visit to their
thanks for my game your game oh that's
okay it's only the marybelle we're all
get you all the way out just hold just
hold still just hold still
lick him from the other side and try to
get him out oh god you made it worse
much worse hey he's trying to shake your
hand there okay no he's not happy
Mother's Day with recording later I
gotta call my mom okay yeah hey guy
you're nuts
well done well done let's go for a ride
whoa we've already been here yeah you
have somewhere new you're you're on the
complete other yeah there's a whole
another side of the map that you can
explore here yeah over there
stop by the gas station first your goat
in that hole get your goat sliding into
that hole I'm pretending that I'm riding
the go jump again she was just dancing
why do you gotta be in that guy was just
talking on that girl you talk you can't
actually talking on that girl bro he was
go Tilly talking on that girl bro I
can't believe how expensive beers were
at that bar they were like six dollars
you target a family got a reference
there yeah well you said that dude was
talking on that girl so I assume that's
what you were doing totally talking on
that girl
I was totally talking on that girl she
was going to come home and bound me I
totally wanted to bound my girlfriend I
was finally going to bone my girlfriend
but then we saw the Sasquatch but she
said she was no I used to be an
adventurer but Sam Jefferson you off
fight em too - this is reminiscent of
something we did last night
Oh last night oh you weren't really
there for it you were just singing
pictures oh I know he's tired by the
ring if they're only candles here
oh come on you know your ability to ring
is why was that I will give someone a
hundred bucks if they know what the hell
I'm talking about there oh you did it
what the hell I just reeking horrifying
you're a buff go now weird now you have
to maintain so
stronger you could edit me out you can
hit him hard now go far
real good rock so just get off get off
me this is not if you look straight
oh if you look if you're looking to
trade up you'll see oh you should go to
the no gravity death utility turn raked
no streak that is the low gravity taking
credulity the one that says low gravity
testing jump over the fence by jumping
and pressing Q rated defend area jump
[Laughter]
yeah go through the air by the brown
ones which are weaker dad not quite
right there
good job you did I just gave ragdoll
glitch
ragdoll glitch through everything in
this game you can actually I'm know we
haven't even touched the surface of the
different game breaking there come on
giraffe goat it's a goat so tall goats
nhadra it's it's just it's not even it's
a giraffe completely doesn't even sort
of look like it go but it's all yeah I'm
a saw that is a very tall go tall would
be accurate as it was work go figure
right yeah oh no you're very much
hanging
Oh God ah spitting planes on the ceiling
[Music]
now look you're flying fly isn't this a
magical adventure why am i flying
because you're in the low gravity
testing facility yeah that we establish
that already no it's not really there's
a bunch of fans that's a goat okay and
this is low gravity you need to start
believing outside the box here because
things are about to get really weird how
do I go lower
do I need a good reference that was a
family-friendly reference this good
family-friendly front frame leaf or in
the same episode you gotta close yes is
this good yeah that's another section of
the low gravity testing facility it
appears to just be a little applies it's
also the low gravity test see Oh God
oh-ho-ho Hey look your goat uh what's
happening I don't know what you're doing
I'm not moving the mouse I figured -
babe okay that van is supposed to lead
to the ceiling and you're stuck I think
we need to do I'm just gonna rag doll
into it I got it ragdoll up higher I
don't think you're gonna be able to do
that you are a master of this game Jesus
councilman why don't I give you a high
five
[Music]
I'm not stupid